CHRIS CARDE: So hi everyone.
I'd like to welcome you
all to this special
Google I/O tech talk.
This is just one of very few
where we invite an external
partner to come in and talk
about what they're doing with
Google products.
So my name is Chris Carde.
I'm a Technical Program Manager
in our Munich office.
I work in our automotive team,
and our team focuses on
putting the right products and
APIs into the hands of car
makers to enable awesome
Google-powered navigation and
infotainment systems.
So we have a long history of
working with Mercedes.
It's been years now.
Back in 2008, they were one of
the first car companies to
launch Send to Car.
This is an integration from
Google Maps that allows users
to send destination businesses
directly from Google Maps to
their connected car.
They've continued to innovate
since then.
They've launched Google Local
Search and Street View built
into a number of their cars.
And actually, I believe just
yesterday, they announced the
new 2014 S Class with built-in
Google Maps.
So we're pretty excited about
Mercedes Drive, if you will,
to integrate connectivity and
Drive innovation, and that
brings us to today.
So Daimler came to us with
this new smartphone and
app-based platform.
They'll tell you a lot more
about it in their talk, but
what excites us is that
packaging these features into
a smartphone app really enables
them to innovate and
iterate at a pace that's
basically been unheard of in
automotive.
So we saw this great opportunity
to work with them
to help them bring connected
cars into the reality that our
Google Maps users have been
experiencing for years now,
and that's basically a fast,
predictive search for
businesses and addresses, and
a rich visualization of
results on a map.
So there are probably
two types of
people in the audience.
There are people here who build
cars, and then there are
people here who build
other things.
And I've talked a number
of people at the show.
It's probably the
people who build
cars are in the minority.
We've asked Mercedes to kind
of split the difference
because there's some interesting
stories they can
tell about automotive
challenges, but we'd also like
them to provide this broadly
applicable case study for how
they've taken the Google Maps
and Places APIs and built this
rich, beautiful product
of their own.
So without further delay, I'd
like to hand it over to Kal
Mos and Mike Cheng from
Mercedes, and they will tell
you about the digital
Drive style app.
KAL MOS: Thank you, Chris.
Hello, everyone.
Thanks a lot for coming
today to listen to us.
I will walk you through our
experience implementing Google
Places and the API, and I will
hand the microphone after that
to Mike Cheng, who is leading
the development on our team at
Mercedes Benz to dive deeper
into the code and talk about
some of his experiences
with the code.
I work for Mercedes
Benz Research and
Development North America.
Our office is actually in
Palo Alto south of here.
And as Chris said, we've
been working with
Google for a while.
So actually, when you buy a
Mercedes Benz car today, it
comes equipped with some of
Google's services already.
The way it works today is that
we have an embedded head unit.
There is a head unit that is
already coming with the car.
HeadUnit is what you used to
call in the old days radio.
It's now a computer running
multiple different
features in the car.
We offer different Google
browser-based services within
that embedded HeadUnit.
And we get the connectivity
either via Bluetooth phone
paired to the car or via
embedded telephony in North
America using M-brace
system that we
have for safety features.
The features that are offered
usually in these cars, you get
Google Local Search, you get
Street View, you get Panorama
View, and if you are buying the
new S Class that was just
released yesterday, you get also
Google Maps and a full
implementation of Google Maps.
So we know that people come
to the car with their
smartphones, and there is always
a question of what
drivers actually want when they
get into the car with
their smartphone.
In most of the cars today, you
will be able to access your
contents from your phone.
So you have some private
contents, you have your music.
Can access your music,
for example.
You can access your
address book, you
can make phone calls.
But drivers want more.
And there is a study
that actually was
conducted by JD Power.
They actually went to drivers
who had navigation systems in
their car and asked them
what did they want?
And what they got back from
drivers is that they want an
easy and feature rich smartphone
integration.
So it's not just about contents
from the smartphone.
They want the features from
smartphone to be integrated,
and they want it to be easy,
and that's a key word here.
They want to use smartphone
for navigation.
So those are actually drivers,
not in Mercedes Benz cars, but
in all different cars.
47% of them downloaded a
navigation app and used it
while they had actually an
embedded navigation experience
in their cars.
So there is some kind of
growing preference for
navigation apps running
on smartphones.
And when the study dived deeper
into the reason for
that, they found that
destination input and
selection is a major pain
point for drivers.
And six out of the top 10
problems with the navigation
system they cited in that study
where actually related
to input and selection
of the destination.
The study concludes with
this statement.
One-shot destination
entry is the dream.
So that's what we have
out there from
that study by JD Power.
So we looked at what
we have internally.
We have a system that's running
on a smartphone.
The system is called
Digital DriveStyle.
It's an application, runs
on the smartphone.
And with that, once you run on
a smartphone, you get the
quick update cycle, which
basically you can virtually
release a new version of the
application every couple of
weeks if you want to.
And that helps us and offers us
an opportunity to continue
the innovation cycle
with that.
We can add features, we can
modify features, and we can
adjust the customer's
demand very quickly.
We also are able to harness the
power of the smartphone.
It's not a secret to anyone
here that smartphone is
leading in the hardware
and software areas
of innovations today.
They are running now very,
very powerful processors.
And as you probably can see
around us, outside this room,
lots of things are running
around the platforms itself
like Android platform,
for example.
So we brought all of these
advantages of smartphone and
the ecosystem of smartphone
applications, and we run this
in the car.
So once you get into the
car, you connect your
phone to the car--
you actually use the
car displays.
You use a system like the audio
system in the car, the
speakers in the car, the
microphone in the car, the
input mechanism of the car.
So you don't touch the phone
once you get into the car.
The whole logic is coming
from the phone.
All the screens are actually
rendered on the phone, but you
don't do even feel that as you
are driving your car and
interacting with the system.
The specific application here,
the Digital DriveStyle that
you see, it has three main
categories of features.
It has Social, it has Media,
and it has Places.
Social basically gives you a
safe, non-distracting way to
access your social
media networks.
For example, you can access your
Facebook, you can access
your Twitter feed.
You can access also your
Google+, as we show actually
in the vehicles out there.
And Media will get you access
your on board media if you
have some music stored on the
phone, some files that you
purchased on the phone, or you
can also access your connected
music like internet radio.
You can access your personalized
radio.
So that's also possible
with this application.
Places is a complete turn by
turn navigation on board, and
on board here means on
the phone itself.
So we have the Maps locally
stored on the phone, and we
have the whole navigation
engine, route matching, and
destination entry
on the phone.
That product is actually
available on iPhone.
It's already released
last year.
It's available in about 20
different markets, and we
started from that.
We looked at that, and we
actually in the process of
developing the Android version
of this too to
run on Android phones.
But that's what we
have out there.
And we looked into what we can
do with that and what we can
add into this.
So the first thing that we, of
course, thought about is how
to make that on board navigation
engine that is not
connected, how do you make it
a hybrid navigation engine?
How do you had the connectivity
piece of it to
interact with Google Places and
become basically a hybrid
navigation system?
So we did a lot of things, and
you can watch them and
experience them in the car that
we brought out in the
Sandbox area of Google Maps.
But I will focus here and we
will focus our talks on three
different things we consider
kind of major, and we would
like to discuss this
with you today.
The one thing that stands out
is a single text box-based
destination entry.
Basically, what you have in
Google Maps for years is now
available in the car.
You don't have to think about,
I'm going to search, or I'm
going to input a
street address.
You don't have to think
about these things.
You just type what you want
and the system has an
autocomplete function powered
by Google Places API to find
what you want.
And in few clicks as you are
trying to find the address,
Google Places API will propose
for you a few selections that
you pick the destination from.
So that was actually one of the
new things that we tried
to address based on the study
that we saw from JD Power, and
we are happy to have it
today in our cars.
And at least six of the top 10
major problems that customers
are complaining from probably
are gone with this.
The second thing is once you
are in the car and you're
actually driving from Point A to
Point B, you probably want
to know more about Point A or
Point B or something in
between, so we offer you this
kind of rich metadata and
visual information that helps
you while you're driving to
get more information about
your drive experience.
So we enable you to review
Google+ local photos.
We enable you to browse Street
Views around the destination
that you're going to.
If you are actually driving to
a business location, we let
you see the ratings or
the opening hours.
And of course, you can make
phone calls and call and order
pizza if you're doing to a pizza
place to pick up your
pizza, or make a reservation
in a restaurant.
And at the end of the day, you
most likely want to navigate,
so we let you get, of course,
turn by turn directions to the
destination.
And in many other cases, you
just want to glance and get an
idea about your surrounding
environment.
So we added the ability to
overlay real time information
on Google Maps.
So you can actually just glance
and see the weather in
the area around you, or you can
see the traffic situation
in the area around you.
So that's the third thing that
I would like to discuss and
highlight today here
in the talk.
There were some challenges,
of course, like any other
interesting development
project.
And I will talk about some
of the automotive related
challenges we faced.
In automotive in anything we do,
there are a few challenges
that come whether we integrate
with Google or we integrate
with other features and
service providers.
The automotive related
challenges that we have, one
of them is the reliability
requirements.
Probably not too many of you
developed automotive
applications before, but
all of you drive car.
And as you're driving the car,
the last thing you expect is
to have a system that hangs in
the car or the need to restart
a system in the car.
That's completely unacceptable
and unheard of, and customers
do not expect that and
will not allow that.
So that's a little
bit different.
We all want to develop
bug-free features and
applications, but the reality
is there are a few bugs.
How you judge those bugs, some
of the things that you might
look at in a mobile environment,
like on the
smartphone, something that you
could fix in the next release,
we cannot release it with.
It's a showstopper for us.
We stop.
We have to fix them.
So reliability requirements
here are extremely high in
automotive environment.
Even though the app is running
on smartphone, but once you
get in the car, you see it on
the car display so it's a part
of the car system, and
immediately, the expectations
of customers are different.
The second thing is
release cycle.
We of course can update the app
every couple of weeks on
the phone, but what happens
on the car side?
The app has to talk to some
hardware on the car side, and
that hardware somehow is
also related to the
car development cycle.
And the car development cycle,
as you all know, is probably
between three to four years.
And we can release an app
every couple of weeks.
So how do you match these
two different cycles?
So that's an issue that
we had to deal with.
We have also that hardware
that lives in the car to
receive the contents from the
applications and display them
on the car side.
It has to be automotive grade.
And automotive grade means
many different things.
The hardware, to be automotive
grade, means lots
of different things.
But in general, it's about
temperature range.
It has to work in Alaska, it has
to work in Mojave Desert
if you leave the car
for a week there.
It has to work everywhere in
extreme heat and extreme cold
environments.
It has to work under different
conditions of vibrations.
So if you're driving on a
concrete road, on a dirt road,
on an asphalt road, different
conditions for vibrations, it
has to follow and work within
an environment that's very
challenging from a mission
point of view.
And there are so many other
things for automotive grade
hardware that we actually have
to follow and make sure our
hardware will actually become,
at the end of the day, an
automotive grade hardware.
What that means is that we
cannot just tap to an existing
pool of hardware that's
available out there.
And for any hardware to be put
in the car, it has to go
through a very rigid and tedious
process of being
qualified as an automotive grade
hardware and maybe even
change it to become an
automotive grade hardware
which makes it, of course, a
little bit more expensive and
also makes it a little bit late
to come to the market.
So I cannot just step to the
chipset that was just released
last week and put
it in my car.
I will have to take it into
a process to make it an
automotive grade hardware.
Last but not least, the
driver distraction.
As you are inside your
car, you are driving.
That's the main job of every
driver is to drive.
Eyes on the road, hands
on the wheel.
Anything else is actually
secondary.
Anything else is background.
So our application has to
function in a way that's not
distracting for the driver,
and that is itself a big
challenge because even though
there are guidelines,
interpreting the guidelines and
following the guidelines
is a big challenge.
There are AAM guidelines in
North America, there is ISO
guidelines in Europe, there is
JAMA guidelines in Japan.
And we follow all these
guidelines and we designed the
app to satisfy all
these guidelines.
Now, some challenges are also
related to how you implement
Google Places API in
that environment.
The first one is the end
to end use case.
We are actually stitching
two things together.
We are still using the on board
navigation maps and on
board navigation core, and
actually augmenting that and
adding to that the information
and the experiences we're
getting from Google
Places API.
And at the end of the day,
customers do not need to worry
about that, do not need
to care about that.
The customer needs just end to
end experience that's smooth
and seamless, and that provided
a challenge for us.
The second thing is the reality
of cellular coverage.
It's not a secret that you are
driving in the United States
especially in many areas
that do not have
good cellular coverage.
You get from 3G to 2G, and then
sometimes you get to zero.
There is no G at all.
There is nothing.
There is no connectivity
at all.
And if you are in the middle
of [INAUDIBLE]
entry and you are making a
request to Google back end to
get the information and you lose
connectivity, what are
you going to do?
So the fallback scenario on how
you gracefully fall back
when you make requests and you
don't get an answer and how
the user will see that in
front of it is a great
challenge here because customers
expect the system to
work, obviously.
And then assuming that we solve
the end to end use case
problem and we have good
coverage and you've got the
information, now how can you
stitch all these different
databases together?
These databases, they have
different formats.
They're optimized for different
conditions.
And just trying to get the right
information to show in
the right location is a
challenge in itself.
So how did we think about ways
to make a successful
automotive App Engine?
How did we do that?
For DriveStyle App, we developed
a strategy that's
based on very few
requirements.
The first one is to focus
on user experience,
not number of features.
So we actually have access to a
huge number of features and
we pick and choose
few of them.
We don't offer everything.
We offer a few of them.
If for some of you, it makes
sense to have 200 different
apps on your phone, probably for
many of you, you wouldn't
need that in the car.
You need a few that are done
right, and that's what we are
focusing on here.
We focused on social.
We know that people now, they
have their own digital
lifestyle, and we know that the
car is part of that and in
many cases, that goes
around social.
So in Digital DriveStyle, we
made sure that your navigation
is part of your social
experience, your media is part
of your social experience,
and vice versa.
So social is a core component
in everything we do.
And context is also extremely
important in car environment
because you don't have a lot
of time to choose from
multiple options.
So we use context here to limit
the number of things.
So when you do a search for
pizza, we don't show you the
pizza everywhere around
in the United States.
We show you just the pizza
around your location because
most likely, that's what
you're looking for.
So context is extremely
important in that regard.
We don't develop the app and
then adjust it to satisfy
driver distraction requirements
or to avoid
driver distraction.
We don't do that.
We actually design the app from
the beginning, one of the
input and constraints in the
design is the driver
distraction guidelines.
So we start with that,
not end with that.
And that's extremely important
because it's in the DNA of the
app itself that it will
run in a car.
Then we keep, as much as
possible, logic and
information on the phone side
because we know that is the
side that we control better.
We can update that
much faster.
And there is some software, of
course, living on the hardware
in the car, but we minimize that
to the minimal amount in
order to be able to innovate
much faster
independent of the car.
What is the long term goal?
So what we want, at the end of
the day, at one point, is a
seamless experience
in navigation and
in everything else.
So you basically don't have to
send information from your
laptop to the car or from
your phone to the car.
We want the information
to be available.
We want one state for you
navigation, whether you are
working on your desktop or
working on your laptop, on
your smartphone, or you're
actually getting in the car,
the state is maintained and the
state is available for you
for navigation and for
other features too.
So that's what we would like
to have at the end.
And we will get there.
We'll get to that point
eventually.
So I would like now to pass the
microphone to Mike Cheng
from our team to talk a little
bit about the implementation.
MIKE CHENG: Thanks, Kal.
So I'd like to share with all of
you some of our experiences
and lessons learned in
developing the DriveStyle
application and bringing the
Places API into this product.
I'd like to cover how to improve
traditional address
entry and destination entry,
and then we'll move on and
talk a little bit about how
to create a system that's
connected and brings information
from the web into
the product.
And then we'll talk a little
bit about the Google Maps
solutions that we use in the
Digital DriveStyle app.
So let's start with the
destination entry.
This screen is probably familiar
to a lot of you.
It's the traditional
address entry flow.
So at the top, you have entry
fields for state, and then you
select a city, and then you
select a street, and then if
you want, you can go select
a house number.
And even after that, you can
select an intersection
if you wanted to.
This is a really tedious process
because each entry
that you go into, you need to
then go into the speller and
type it out.
And this is so tedious to use
while driving that, according
to the AAM standards
in the US, it's not
allowed while driving.
So you need to be stopped on
the side of the road or in
your garage, for example.
But I think the bigger issue
here is that people don't
really use street addresses
anymore.
Just like how on your phone you
have phone numbers, but
you get the phone number
from your friend once
and then it's stored.
It's stored on your device.
It's stored in the
cloud somewhere.
It's stored in your
social network.
So what can we do to improve
the experience?
So we took a close look at how
Google manages this product.
So we look to Google Maps
online, and we really want
this experience of, instead of
telling my navigation system
where I want to go, I should
tell it what want to do.
The solution should help me
reduce the number of inputs
that I need to enter.
So you see here that I type in
C-O-F, and already, I have
suggestions for coffee shops
and businesses matching
"coffee." And most importantly,
we need to make
this safe to use
while driving.
So with that in mind, we've
taken advantage of the Places
Query Autocomplete APIs.
it's a really nice API that
returns us a mixed list of
query suggestions--
so coffee bean, coffee,
coffee shops--
as well as a few business
names, so Coffee Inc and
Coffee Bar.
You see on the right
here that it's not
limited to just queries.
You can actually start
typing in an address.
So 800 H matches to 800 Howard
Street, which is actually the
address for the Moscone
Center for people
who don't know addresses.
If I type in 850, it immediately
matches our office
in Palo Alto at 850
Hanson Way.
And so typically with three
or four characters, I can
actually get exactly what I
want, and this enables a user
experience that's much more
similar to Google Maps than
what we had before.
So let's take a look at what
happens underneath, just at a
very high level.
At the top, you see boxes
for the Google Places
queries that we make.
These are API endpoints that
we have access to.
At the bottom, you get an
example of the responses
coming back from
these queries.
So if we type in the example
from before, C-O-F, we put
this into the Places Query
Autocomplete, the Autocomplete
API returns us the list of
coffee bean, coffee, coffee
shops, coffee drink,
coffee bar.
But these are just
string results.
It doesn't have any metadata
associated with it.
So the next step that we need
to take is we need to take
that coffee query completion and
then put it into the Place
Search API.
So this Place Search API will
actually return me businesses
or establishments or street
addresses, for example.
You see here that there's
some duplication.
So the two items on the bottom
for the Query Autocomplete
also show up for Place Search,
so we'll try to optimize for
that a little bit.
But the Place Search will give
us a reference that we can
then put into the Place Details
API to get back rich
metadata about this location
such as the lat, long, the
opening hours, review
data, and so on.
So actually, what's new since
about two days ago, the Places
Query Autocomplete API Response
does return you the
reference for locations such
as 800 Howard Street.
So this is really handy because
in our flow that we
saw before, we basically
remove an entire step.
So that's an entire request to
the network, and you need to
wait for a response.
We've simplified it from three
requests down to two.
So that's really helping us in
improving the performance for
our customers, and I'll talk a
little bit later about why you
should not count on the
network being there.
So here, we have a
comparison video.
On the left, you have the
traditional address entry, and
then on the right, you
have the address
entry powered by Google.
I'll play this video
really quick.
Watch the right very closely
because it goes quick.
On the left side, it
takes a little bit
longer, and you'll see.
So here we go.
On the right side, we
have a search field.
We type in 1, and immediately,
we have 1600
Amphitheater Parkway.
We select it, and then we go,
we calculate a route, and
we're done.
So that was about 10 seconds.
On the left, we're still
typing in Amphitheater.
OK.
House number 1600.
And there we go.
So on the right with the Places
API, we've cut down the
amount of time it takes
to enter an
address by two thirds.
So the one on the right takes
10 seconds, the one on the
left takes 30 seconds.
So we expect this to be a huge
improvement to the product.
We expect it to be the best
implementation, actually, of
destination entry in any
automotive product when it's
released next month.
So let's talk about going
beyond street addresses.
So again, we look at for the
Google Maps APIs again and
Google Maps Web Service, and we
see that we have a lot of
social features.
So you see that we have Street
View here, we have Photos, we
have Reviews and Ratings.
So this is how we've brought
this into our product.
Using the Place Details API, you
get all this information
for star ratings and
opening hours.
We also get the Google+
Local Photos back,
which is very nice.
It feels like you've been to
that location without actually
having been there.
And of course, the immersity
of Google Street View
experience, which I highly
recommend everybody to go to
our SL 550 outside to experience
for yourself.
A little bit about blending
online data with offline maps.
Don't count on having a
network connection.
You could be driving through the
desert or driving through
the forest or coming to Google
I/O where there's no network
connection whatsoever.
Cache as much as you can.
Cache aggressively.
Don't block or restrict the UI
or the flow if you don't have
a network connection
because customers
absolutely hate that.
Map data can be different or
incomplete, so with an off
board solution where you're
grabbing everything from the
internet, the data is always
constantly updating.
And in markets such as China,
actually, there are actually
lots of changes being made to
the infrastructure constantly,
so streets are being built,
businesses are moving around,
and it's most likely not going
to match your on board data.
And then finally,
be careful with
geocodes and reverse geocodes.
If you have an address and you
convert that into a lat long,
don't convert it back
to an address.
It's not going to be
the same address.
Just be consistent in how you
store this information and how
you present it to the user.
And then finally, unique maps.
Our product actually takes
advantage of the Google Maps
SDK for iOS.
It's a really nice library that
you can integrate into
your product.
You link a few libraries and
you reference a resource
bundle, and you're basically
ready to go.
It matches very closely to other
map frameworks, so you
get access to all of these 3D
buildings and traffic players
and map types.
And finally, we have our Heatmap
concept, which is
based off of the Places
API Radar Search.
The Radar Search was actually
initially released by Google
in January of this year.
We'll be the first automotive
manufacturer actually to take
advantage of these APIs.
What the API does is it returns
you a point cloud of
200 locations around
a certain location.
So we can generate these
density maps
based off of the data.
So you see the white spots here
are higher density, and
then the darker spots
are lower density.
And it really gives you an idea
of the character of a
certain location if you haven't
been there before.
Just a quick note on the
JavaScript Maps API that we
use for City Guide.
One technique that we've
actually used is instead of
referencing image data stored on
disk, we Base64 encode all
of the image data and feed
it directly into
the JavaScript API.
This gives us a few
advantages.
The JavaScript API, we can sense
this image data without
a network connection.
So once your maps have loaded,
then you can basically change
the overlay as often
as you want.
And the second point is that you
have no need to save the
image data to disk, so you
gain some performance
improvements there.
And that's pretty much it.
So thanks a lot.
We've hopefully given you some
insight into how we've
developed the Digital DriveStyle
app, and please
stop by our Sandbox demo.
CHRIS CARDE: So it looks like
we've got about seven minutes
left for questions.
We have two microphones set up
in the aisles, and if anyone
would like to come up, this
is your chance to ask an
automaker anything about
navigation or infotainment.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I've got a couple use cases that
seem to be pretty common
when I want to go somewhere
in my car.
One, someone texts me an
address, and then I've got to
somehow put that in either the
car nav or my phone, and
that's pretty annoying.
Two, I'm at my desktop, I find
somewhere I want to go, do all
my navigation, figure
out my route.
Now I've got to somehow get
that into my car, too.
Do you foresee some way of
making that transparently
entered into the car nav so that
there's maybe no UI and
it just somehow gets there?
How would you handle
that, I guess?
MIKE CHENG: Yeah.
That's actually a very
interesting problem, one that
we're hoping to solve.
We've kind of handled the
problem the opposite way, so
we've integrated Glimpse
into our product.
And what this does is that we
can actually send our current
location to a third party
so that they know
where you are, at least.
I think the next step to that
is to bring it the other way
around so that somebody can send
you a destination or you
can send yourself
a destination.
CHRIS CARDE: And I should point
out that Google Maps
does already have a feature
called Send To Car.
We do integrate with a number of
automakers to allow you to
send an address directly
from Google Maps
to a connected vehicle.
AUDIENCE: Another question.
What about voice control
integration in the car?
I just represents a company that
develops technological
systems for the car called
Robin service.
KAL MOS: So the application
itself
today runs on the iPhone.
We have Siri integration
completely
integrated in the product.
On the Android version that we
are working on, we are looking
into integrating the Google
Voice as part of that.
You have text to speech built
in on board, so there is
always text to speech to read
stuff back to you, to read
your Facebook postings and the
different information to you.
But more than that, just for the
interaction itself, we're
going to depend on the voice
integration that comes with
the phone itself.
AUDIENCE: OK, I look in
our products also.
It's right there.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned having
to comply with automotive
grade hardware.
What about the consumer-provided
cell phone?
Is that considered automotive
grade, or did you have to do
anything special for that?
KAL MOS: No.
Of course, the phone itself
is whatever phone you buy.
It's usually not automotive
grade.
Today, you will still have to
plug the phone, but we offer
the phone a place where you can
plug it close to you, like
in the armrest, for example,
where you can plug it.
Usually, you don't leave a phone
in the car, and that's a
huge difference from the
hardware itself.
The hardware is always
in the car.
When you park the car
in the desert for 10
hours, it is there.
But your phone is always in your
pocket, and that's why
the problem is not that
severe with the phone.
The phone is usually with you,
and once you come into the
car, the phone is usually within
your vicinity, and
that's always air conditioned
and a nice environment that
doesn't really have to satisfy
lots of automotive grade
requirements.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm interested to know where you
think it will be in, say,
five years down the line?
What's your ambition for the
socialization of the
automotive experience
at Mercedes Benz?
Is that something you think will
develop in partnership
with Google?
I'm kind of interested to know
how experimental you are right
now with all of these
restrictions you
also have to consider.
KAL MOS: We are as open as
we can be, I would say.
We look into this seamless
experience, really.
We think the car is part of
your digital lifestyle.
We need to maintain the state.
I want to have one state
for everything.
Whatever you do on the phone,
I want it to be available in
the car without you sending
anything back and forth.
So that is what I'm looking at,
is that whatever the next
greatest applications and
features that Google will come
up with and other companies
will come up with, I want
these to be immediately
available in the car without
needing to synchronize and send
things back and forth.
So that's, I think,
where we can go.
And what we're trying to do is
to develop a platform that we
can easily provide that.
So it's a platform that runs
on a phone, so I can always
push the newest and greatest
update to it.
I open information on the car
side as much as possible so I
can take advantage of the
sensors in the car and merge
that with all the information
that comes from the back end.
The vision that we have for the
car really is that because
the car, at the end of the
day, is your friend.
It knows about you.
It knows about your customs
and habits.
It knows about what you did on
your phone a few minutes ago.
And you should not come to the
car every time and start from
zero again.
You should just continue what
you've been doing as you get
in the car.
And the only difference,
of course,
is that you're driving.
So that's our job, is to make
sure that you can continue
what you were doing but in a
safe, non-distracting way.
AUDIENCE: In the future, is it
planned to be across every
single variation of
Mercedes vehicle?
KAL MOS: Well actually, the app
is offered now in most of
our car lines.
So it's offered in the
A class, B class,
E class, and CLA.
We're offering it one by one
to all different models.
So that's the target, yes.
There is a heavy focus, of
course, on the new cars.
It's a little bit hard to go
backwards and try to offer it
for existing customers on
the road for 10 years.
But that's part of what we're
trying to do that once we
offer it now, it will actually
live with you in
the coming few years.
And even five years from now,
you can still have the latest
and greatest experience
in a car that you
bought five years ago.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRIS CARDE: OK, well, I think
we're just about out of time.
Thank you very much
for coming.
We'll be available in the
Sandbox area for at least 15
minutes, 30 minutes thereafter
to answer questions.
Come see us.
Come see the demo.
Thanks again.